[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con unas
acompaña a harold andrés cortes la verde
el ex personero distrital de la ciudad
de cali en colombia epicentro de las
protestas nacionales y afectadas por
hechos de violencia presionar yo gracias
por estar con nosotros en france 24 le
pregunto el reporte general o el balance
que ha vivido la ciudad con todas estas
protestas
desafortunadamente en algunos espacios y
en algunas partes de la ciudad
algunas personas se aprovecharon de esto
y montaron quizás o quizás se abusaron
del derecho de la protesta pacífica y lo
que hicieron fue hacerle daño a la
ciudad a vandalizar
los bienes que son de todos los caleños
los bienes del mío por ejemplo muchas
estaciones vandalizadas creo que
aproximadamente 11 se acabaron todas
destruyeron todas las cámaras de
seguridad la ciudad pero también dentro
de estas manifestaciones otras acciones
que se dieron violentas en la ciudad hay
que decir también que la policía
reaccionó pues cumpliendo su deber
constitucional y desafortunadamente en
un momento de esto de confrontación a
veces la fuerza no es fácil medirla de
parte y parte personal yo le pregunto si
hay conocimiento de detenidos o
investigaciones sobre los vídeos que se
han conocido en las redes sociales donde
personas vestidas de blanco
presuntamente habrían disparado con la
supuesta complicidad de las autoridades
llega la minga indígena
llevamos varios días de bloqueo en
palabras de algunos caleños se sienten
secuestrados se siente con miedo y ante
la imposibilidad
lo que se ha manejado es que no hay de
pronto una acción efectiva por parte de
la policía en dar alguna protección de
manera desafortunada decidieron armarse
y salir a las calles a proteger un
sector de la ciudad situación que
también es condenado desde la
personalidad de santiago de cali porque
esto no puede ocurrir no puede haber
y civiles armados ni mucho menos estarle
disparando la humanidad de otra persona
provenga de donde provenga por eso es
claro el llamado que he hecho total
rechazo y total condena a la violencia
provenga de donde provenga ahora por
último le quiero preguntar cómo está el
abastecimiento en la ciudad tanto de
alimentos y combustibles
tenemos desabastecimiento de alimentos
tenemos desabastecimiento de combustible
tenemos desabastecimiento de algunos
elementos de primera mano en la ciudad
que los últimos días se empezó a
escalonar un poco porque a través de los
acuerdos y a través de la concertación
logramos crear unos corredores
humanitarios
en las fronteras de la ciudad el ingreso
a la ciudad donde los manifestantes
permitían que ingresaran alimentos a los
alimentos permitían que ingresara
combustible se llevó al acuerdo para
insumos médicos llegó el acuerdo para el
ingreso del oxígeno que hoy se está
necesitando en cali en todas las
ciudades del país por el tema de
pandemia parece que se nos hubiera
olvidado que todavía estamos en medio
del coi 19 y fue un tema que era
prioritario para poder surtir a todas
estas alas de isis de la ciudad que está
atendiendo a todos los pacientes que
desafortunadamente salieron contagiados
con este virus hemos estado trabajando
también porque se ha empezado a
desabastecimiento por ejemplo de los
químicos que que dan tratamiento al
acueducto para aguas que los caleños
consumimos este hemos estado trabajando
contra el reloj y contra el tiempo hemos
logrado que esto haya entrado haya
empezado a ingresar paulatinamente
hoy no tenemos los niveles esperados de
abastecimiento en todo este tema vemos
en la ciudad largas filas para tanquear
se ha proferido un decreto de 'pico y
placa' por así decirlo sea también en
ese decreto se ha establecido un valor
límite para el tanque de motos y de
vehículos en moto solamente pueden
tanquear diez mil pesos los vehículos
particulares hasta 40 mil pero realmente
la prioridad es hoy es el ingreso de
alimentos a la ciudad el
desabastecimiento es grande es grande y
en ello estamos trabajando
personeros gracias por su tiempo y por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24
ustedes también gracias continúen con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias
[Música]